in the snowy wastes of western ukraine
british supplied anti-tank missiles
being put through their paces
if russia does launch an invasion of
tanks they can expect this kind of
reception
but how soon that invasion could happen
is reportedly now causing a rift between
the u.s and ukraine
while america says an imminent
invasion's a real possibility ukraine's
president vladimir zelinsky is insisting
it isn't there are those who suspect
that you are talking down the threat of
an imminent invasion just to preserve
your economy and actually the americans
are right it is a real possibility that
that could happen imminently
is that what's really going on here
we do understand what's happening and
we're talking about this we're talking
about this with our people but we have
been in this situation for eight years
so we shouldn't be only looking up we're
also looking on the ground and for us
it's an important question
we may lose the current economy of our
country people come first
in an air of questions the president was
asked again and again about differences
with america
president zielenski has been walking a
fine line between his government's
position and america's assessment of the
threat russia currently poses his
officials though have been more blunt
one ukrainian security official said
today allies should supply weapons but
otherwise keep quiet
it's all welcome news to vladimir putin
as the russian leader keeps the world
guessing about his intentions his
foreign minister was sounding diplomatic
our president already said that if our
attempts to negotiate over suitable
security guarantees in europe does not
give any result then we will respond
answering that direct question about
what kind of response it could be he
said any kind my decision will be based
on our military leaders proposals
but america's ambassador to moscow
wasn't convinced
it's the equivalent of uh if you and i
were we're having a discussion or
negotiation if i put a gun on the table
and say that i come in peace
uh you know that's uh that's that's
threatening
the daily feed of russian propaganda
goes on while talking diplomacy it seems
russia is still preparing its military
for conflict
dominic waghorn sky news kiev